[Musique]
cette allée rts de saint-benoît que
s'est organisée la semaine de la
protection de l'enfance qui a pour but
de prévenir les difficultés auxquelles
les parents peuvent être confrontés
alors l'objectif de cette rencontre
c'était qu'on puisse avec qui rts et la
pjj parlait de la protection de
l'enfance et que les professionnels qui
sont en cours de formation actuellement
puisse faire des rencontres avec le
secteur associatif avec le sigle et les
services du département pour pouvoir
concrètement parler de ce qu'on attend
lorsque les travailleurs sociaux dans un
dispositif
quels qu'ils soient abordés on va dire
les réalités du métier les
problématiques globales
autour de la protection de l'enfance les
attentes les enjeux puisqu'il ya eu
quand même beaucoup d'évolution depuis
ces cinq dernières années où ces dix
dernières années
fruit d'une étroite collaboration entre
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
du ministère de la justice de liberté s
de saint-benoît et du conseil
départemental de la réunion celle ci
permettra de développer la construction
de l'ingénierie pédagogique
c'est important de s'adresser aux
étudiants qui seront les futurs
travailleurs sociaux dont l'essentiel
travaillera sur l'île et de montrer le
travail engagé alléchant la direction à
la chaux de direction et du conseil
départemental et la protection du cheikh
de la jeunesse parce que on est sur les
mêmes missions et que les stagiaires les
stagiaires du marin arriveront sur les
services et pour arriver sur les sur les
deux services
[Musique]